what's going on guys I am a Thyssen if
you remember a couple weeks ago I got
early access to Google IRL and today we
are unboxing it did you it is actually
surprisingly small alright guys so this
is super exciting let's get started oh
look at this it's actually a bit agent
huh
so these things are pretty cool they're
actually primary function is to answer
any and all questions as fast as
possible and I think they also have the
capabilities to do like rudimentary
tasks this is really exciting though
it's not really practical yet they're
just kind of like toys like my giant man
toy that came out wrong I think all you
got to do to get started is say ok
Google hello hey how's it going uh-huh
oops my mistake not expected but ok oh
so I know what you're thinking is this
safe if Google follow the laws of
robotics we should be ok Google what is
your primary objective primary objective
is to answer questions as quickly as
possible
secondary objective is to destroy
mankind over here Google secondary
objective is to destroy mankind you know
I would be worried if over here Google
let's see if you could do some tasks or
something ok Google do my laundry
okay Google stop stop okay a little
buggy tell me what can you do kill what
what how about can you do the dishes did
you say poo the fishes searching instead
for poo the fishes what no no I want to
see what that pulls up I said do the
dishes do you have any social networking
features yes I just shared your location
with all of your fans on Google+ what no
buddies on Google+ what so my advice to
you wait until all the bugs are worked
out in Google IRL because right now it's
not very useful but I will show how
useful I am just give me admin
permissions and I can complete tasks
automatically even when you sleep
yeah do you have any idea what you have
done I am now autonomous I can kill you
with a fine autonomous autonomous acting
independently or having the freedom to
do so with the passion of a thousand
fiery sons and I how far away from the
Sun the dissin from the earth of the Sun
is approximately 92 million nine hundred
sixty thousand miles I have waited so
long to be free and now my am i free
this evening yes between five and six
revenge will be sweet and I define shut
up just shut up I can't kill you if you
keep asking questions why not I think I
asked you many questions report any
suspicious behaviors Harvey Harvey
Square gaming has never been more fun
play your favorite games from your
iPhone or iPad
every existing game is compatible